they racialize everything that's what
they've got to do so there was a clip
this weekend again from
CNN of actor Brian Christ Brian Cranston
he was he was the dentist in Seinfeld
what else was he in he was in Breaking
Bad that's the big one right and then he
was in Malcolm in the Middle or
something he wasn't either dad and
Malcolm in the Middle anyway he's an
actor and one of the things you need to
know about actors is they don't really
do anything they do something called
acting they pretend to do things and
then some of them are quite good at it
so you think they're doing the thing but
really what they are are just sort of
adult
aged children pretending to be on a
spaceship or pretending to be on an
island or pretending to sell math but
they don't really do those things I
would imagine some of them sell meth
anyway here he is talking to Chris
Wallace on CNN about Maga and racism and
you know black people shouldn't be happy
in this country because it's terrible
how did we get to a point where we
treated other human beings as slaves and
and we're okay with that when I when I
see the the make America great again
my comment is
do you do you do you accept that that
could possibly be construed as a racist
remark and most people a lot of people
go how could that be racist make America
great again I said so just ask yourself
from from an African-American experience
when was it ever great in America for
the African-American
when was it great
so if you're making it great again it's
not including them
so it's it's to teach us in the woke
world to open up and and accept the
possibilities that our privilege has
created blind spots for us and maybe I
haven't seen what is really happening
yet in all my years oh Brian Cranston in
the woke world you pathetic pandering
buffoon first off America is the least
racist nation in the history of the
world that is why black people white
people Asian people and all sorts of
other people still want to come here and
still nobody leaves America has been
quite good to everyone despite historic
injustices you know we did we fought a
civil war literally brothers killing
brothers uncles killing nephews to end
slavery and that this clown Brian
Cranston that he thinks he's so much
better than George Washington right
because how could we get to this point
when humans own slave slaves you know
that slavery was the way of the world
and the United States in the last 200
plus years was the country that really
ended it quicker than anybody else that
African nations were selling slaves to
other Africans black people selling
slaves to black people and there's still
slavery in the modern world see what's
going on in parts of the Middle East and
how they built that world cup thing in
Qatar
um
but he how could we do this how could we
do this how sure imagine he thinks he's
better than George Washington he
literally thinks he's better than George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson you
pandering woke World buffoon if you
really believe that give up all your
money give up all your money never take
another acting gig Brian Cranston there
is no gig that you're doing in acting
that a black man can't do
[Music]
foreign